as i say you've been sending in your
questions all day about inflation so
let's get to them with our expert panel
let me introduce them joining me are the
personal finance expert gemma godfrey uh
chief
economic advisor to the center for
economics and business research and a
former head of the government economic
service vicki price and professor adrian
papps deputy director of the national
institute of economic and social
research a very good evening to you all
thank you very much indeed for joining
us on sky news tonight and our first
question is
a very straightforward one but of course
some very complex answers perhaps
required to it uh it is from mary who
simply asks how does a rise in inflation
affect my wages i want to get all three
of you on this from your different
perspectives and let's uh start with you
gemma i mean it's going to be very very
rare for anybody's wages to keep up with
inflation at these levels isn't it
that's the big challenge is that
inflation really eats into wages so
inflation means an increase in the cost
of living so for every one pound that
was spent um it's expected that people
are going to be spending one pound 11
which means across food housing heating
and transport things are getting more
expensive this doesn't necessarily mean
that wages are going up it means that
wages can't go as far so the same wage
won't be able to buy the same amount of
groceries or fill up a car with the same
amount of petrol and it'll only affect
wages if it's actually used to negotiate
a higher salary but from what we've seen
increases in salary are rising by about
half the level that we're seeing being
the cost exceeding it by and so vicky
price that then means people getting
effective pay cuts
but not in all sectors i mean the
interesting thing is if you look at the
private sector they seem to be getting
increases if you add bonuses as well um
which more or less cover the rise in
inflation that we're seeing right now
and if you look at some
sub-sectors within the private sector
areas such as finance for example and
business services are getting above
inflation increases so there is a gap
that's developing right now those are
the particularly those who work for the
public sector are getting very small
increases if you look at the average
figures that we have
until the april month so the last three
months until april those increases were
only 1.5 percent whereas in the private
sector there were eight percent and in
some areas as i said they could be as
high as 11 percent
so i mean it depends clearly what
sectors you're in but overall adrian
perhaps i suppose we should throw in
there in terms of the effect of 9.1 and
perhaps going higher on wages there's
also
quite a few tax rises around for a lot
of people
absolutely it's not just inflation going
up it's taxes going up uh it's
thresholds being frozen so people are
pulled into higher tax brackets than
they would have been
uh had those thresholds being changed
and it's also things like benefits uh
not keeping pace with inflation either
so there is this huge hit to
uh household incomes uh we find that uh
at 60 percent of households have
disposable income that is lower than
some of their
uh bills and therefore there has gonna
have to be lots of changes i'll have to
dip into savings go into arrears or take
out debt uh and of course as
is always the case with such a big shock
the poorest households are being hit
hardest and that's where the policy
mitigation has to uh has to happen ah
good you mentioned that because that's
what our next question leads us into
this
whole idea and you perhaps can explain
more to
us about it about a wage price spiral
greg asks why has the government said it
would be reckless to give everyone a pay
rise in line with inflation we heard
that today the reckless word from the
deputy prime minister uh staying with
you adrian perhaps your your thoughts on
that
well uh look
you know this is a a a complex uh matter
and i don't think we can just say uh a
pay rise equals uh you know a further
increase in inflation inflation is a
combination of expectations and base
effects
and
you know there is a question of you know
how much of this is needed to starve off
uh either poverty for those who are at
the bottom end of the income
distribution but also uh you know will
people actually spend it just to keep uh
you know their heads over the the water
line and to be fair it's not up to
businesses to fight inflation that is a
job for the bank of england the bank of
england has various tools at its
disposal to fight inflation
we can't be saying you know we can't
have any wage increases because
inflation might go up that's simply the
wrong approach inflation is a monetary
policy issue and it should be dealt with
by the bank of england
well vicky price i mean would it be
reckless the government says it would be
to give everyone i mean everyone that it
can give in the public sector i suppose
a pay rise in line with inflation
i don't think it's so much on the
inflation front where we need to worry
it's more that the government is going
to have to borrow rather a lot more than
it's doing already to pay for this now i
mean the question is can they and the
likelihood is that they can um so
there's a serious question nevertheless
in terms of what happens with that pay
if that pay goes to the lower end of the
pay scale which is really where quite a
lot of the public sector right now is in
terms of the increases they have had
which have been hardly in line with
inflation
the lower you are on the pay scale the
more of the money that you've got is
spent on things like
food and energy now both of those areas
are global issues there are things that
as a government here we can't do an
awful lot about unless we reduce vat for
example to find a way in which we can
cut fuel duty even more so you can do a
certain amount but overall those are
global prices that are affected right
now by the war in ukraine particularly
that were already rising of course
so there isn't huge amount that extra
spending on those two areas if that's
what people do
is necessarily going to lead to a
general increase in inflation so i think
we're looking at it from the wrong end
so this worry that if you hand more
money to people of course if you
uh then accelerate perhaps the inflation
and trend already got in other words
that money is used to buy all sorts of
other things up to a point it will um
and that then results in you know a lot
more demand for those things and
therefore higher prices still and we
have shortages up to a point in terms of
labor and also supply constraints supply
chains don't work particularly well then
yes of course it will start pushing
prices uh up uh to a certain extent okay
but the main problem we have is energy
and food and that needs to come down
internationally for it to make an impact
on inflation here i see okay well we've
got a novel suggestion from paul our
next question
uh paul says wages are going up for
large chunks of the workforce at well
below inflation levels we all know that
which means they'll spend far less and
slow the economy further
pretty simple and straightforward but
listen to the suggestion would it be
better to increase pay to near inflation
and
increase interest rates
to five percent um
your thoughts on that gemma from you
know the the personal finance viewpoint
i mean i think
i think it's a fantastic question
because i think we are going to have to
think i think the government should
applaud any type of open uh thinking
kind of creatively to try and work out
how to tackle this situation
unfortunately the challenges are the
challenge of increasing wages
aggressively is that it becomes
unaffordable for businesses and they
then are forced to lay people off so
businesses are also facing higher costs
because they're also facing higher
energy bills high transport costs and
this could also push some you know if
you're adding wages onto that as well
this could push some businesses out of
business and on the other side of the
increasing interest rates makes debt
more expensive so people on a variable
rate mortgage first-time buyers you know
it becomes much harder for them and
again means that people might default on
their mortgage and again
from the business perspective it might
stop businesses from borrowing to invest
and the big risk here just to summarize
it is the big risk here is something
called stagflation which is you have a
high rate of inflation so costs are
rising and rising but unemployment is
actually high i'm not saying it isn't
announced at record lows but if it does
become high because of that that policy
yeah it means that they're going too far
yeah
swings and roundabouts isn't it there's
always winners and losers
depending on the policy choice you make
but adrian perhaps just on that
suggestion from the economist's point of
view is it economically literate to
increase pay to near inflation and at
the same time you've got an inflation
then spiral worry increase interest
rates to five percent to
whack down to bear down on inflation
would that work
i think it's too crass an instrument
though as jenna says it's a really
interesting uh thought experiment
um it's too crass because inflationary
pressures would continue to build uh for
the reasons gemma's already outlined uh
and a hike in interest rates would be
such a shock that we could go into
a much deeper recession than we probably
will uh go into and that that doesn't
really help
because then wages will have to be cut
in order to get us out of the the
recession so
i i just don't think that sort of thing
will work
but i think what's really interesting is
to ask the question who should get a
higher pay rise than they're currently
getting and what can we do about
inflation i mean vicky's absolutely
right there are global factors at play
here uh the war in ukraine uh supply
chain disruptions uh various
complications around brexit
and i think really the question has to
be how do we tackle some of those global
forces while making sure that those on
really low pay who are struggling at the
moment to make ends meet get more
support so i think it's a more
differentiated approach that we need
to certainly have it right but not as
dramatically as from the current level
to five percent okay well we'll be
getting some suggestions about that
targeting uh some questions about it a
little bit later on um but we're gonna
have a break in a moment or two but i
just want to get nitin's question in
which follows on gemma from what you
said in your opening thoughts you know
he says inflation is out of control the
cost of living is unbearable and
although cpi is nine percent some goods
are up 26
are we being taxed through stealth and
this is the point isn't it nine
percent's an average figure it depends
where you live what you buy how you
travel what your personal rate of
inflation is
yeah absolutely and it does affect
different things in terms of not
necessarily for the inflation rate i
mean in general the amount that it's
going to affect you will depend on you
know the level of income tax you're
paying and whether you get a council tax
rebate you know that again there are
certain things that seven people can get
and others can't but in terms of the cpi
the way that the inflation is measured
it's actually tracking the price of a
basket of about 650 items so of course
price of milk absolutely skyrocketing
but we're also saying actually some
costs have have had to fall because
there's less demand so anything to do
with like recreation some things like
that those costs have fallen so it's
meant that on average um the price is
about has increased by nine percent as
opposed to there are absolutely extreme
outliers that are really affecting
families well let's squeeze in one more
question before the break vicky help us
with isaac's question we need prices of
items to be affordable to every citizen
does the government need to get creative
and find other ways of getting tax
instead of coming to the same citizen we
are tired
it's it's a very good point because of
course what we haven't discussed is that
taxes for individuals are going up
anyway so there has been a freezing of
tax allowances income tax allowances
which means that by stealth if you like
we are paying more tax so the government
is collecting a lot of more from us than
would otherwise be the case and with
inflation and with wages going up is
collecting even more so there's plenty
of money that the government is able to
redistribute but of course there are
other more innovative ways such as um
which has been tried already um when
full taxes for example wealth taxes that
could be another way um or taxing other
sectors of the economy which have done
well uh there have been suggestions
about you know supermarkets had done
reasonably well although they hadn't
done well in the first year of the covet
problems that we all had
banks have done well and you know there
are sectors that can possibly afford to
to pay more but we are increasing
corporation tax next year and the real
concern now is that uh you know we may
in fact not even get that increase
because firms are suffering across the
board some sectors doing very well but
loads of small and medium-sized
enterprises suffering and yet so the
taxes have gone up national insurance
has gone up for everybody so we are in a
very strange situation where we are in
fact going to be collecting more
from the economy um if in the next year
or two
whereas of course we need to then
redistribute just as has been said
earlier to those who need it most okay
we're going to take that break right now
plenty more when we come back because
coming up next uh we're going to be
looking at amongst others pensioners
they'll benefit from an inflation linked
increase in their payments well we'll be
asking then our younger generations
bearing the brunt of this cost of living
crisis stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
big stories don't always come from big
cities
i'm lisa dowd and i'm skye's midlands
correspondent and this is where i grew
up
we can reveal that the driver who hit
harry dunn is 42 year old ann sakulas
just met the president and
we never thought we'd get this far
this is what they're up against that the
wind is the really big problems it is
back breaking work and the smoke is
thick
been working well water levels are
dropping but no one knows what impact
further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary we're terrified
in this community i'm told that
everybody knows someone affected by
covid hopefully this will be the last
wave
[Music]
i never knew they would make it it's
amazing
change seems tantalisingly close in this
corner of the uk
wales was the first to introduce the
plastic bag charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
welcome back you're watching sky news
tonight now the rate of inflation as
we've been telling you hit a 40-year
high today so what does this mean for
you for households our panel of experts
have been answering your questions if
you've been with us since the top of the
hour they are personal finance expert
gemma godfrey chief economic advisor to
the center for economics and business
research and the former head of the
government economic service vicki price
and professor adrian papps deputy
director of the national institute of
economic and social research standing by
from all your questions plenty of them
as i say so let's crack on and this one
professor perhaps let me put this to you
from lincoln
puts it this way increasing interest
rates will not slow down these issues
but they will penalize millions with
mortgages how does raising interest
rates impact inflation how does it
matter work
well raising interest rates should mean
uh some reduction in borrowing and
therefore you know some
less money circulating i suppose um and
you know generally reduces some of the
economic activity that does contribute
to inflation now i think it's true to
say that just raising interest rates
alone
won't solve this as we mentioned earlier
there are global forces at work uh
pushing up energy and food prices in
particular there are supply chain
problems that add to all of this uh you
know linked to covert linked to brexit
and and
trade wars that are ongoing so it is a
complex thing interest rates alone won't
do it but it's one way
to uh you know bring down some of the
inflationary pressures and also signal
that the bank of england are very
serious about fighting this and and
inflation is also about expectation what
will happen and how
people might behave and raising interest
rate is both a real measure and a signal
that the bank of england is committed to
fighting with do you think they've gone
just on that i mean you know okay they
they put it up again but i mean still
the interest rate main rate of interest
is still pretty low at 1.25 doesn't it
have to hit something like
four or five percent to deal with this
level of inflation
well i think over time uh it will have
to uh go up uh a lot more than it has
and uh we and others have been arguing
for some time that monetary policy was
too loose but monetary policy is not
only about interest rates it's also
about things like quantitative easing
all the asset
purchases that the bank of ing has been
engaged in since the financial crash
some
uh you know 14 years ago so there's a
whole uh you know hinterland to this
uh above and beyond interest rates yes
interest rates will have to rise more
but you want to set out a gradual path
and communicate your plan quite clearly
to the public and to businesses so they
don't know what to expect uh the fed is
expected to raise interest rates quite
aggressively as it's done in recent
months that is the federal reserve the
central bank of the us
and of course uh some people say it
might reach as as uh you know as high as
four percent by the end of this year i
don't think that'll be the case to the
bank of england but the bank of england
may well follow suit okay well we'll uh
see how that goes let's get to the nub
of the um different groups that are
being treated differently by the
government alex asks this the government
has agreed to reintroduce the triple
lock on pensions meaning pensioners will
benefit from an inflation-linked
increase in their payments inflation
could be 10 percent by the time that
that is set
why are younger generations always
bearing the brunt gemma
and this is a critical question um and
this is why it's so hard for the
government to be able to put out a
policy that really benefits the people
that are struggling the most um because
obviously there is pressure to help
people pensioners aren't able to go and
earn more money so find that makes sense
but i mean we saw this as well whenever
they came out with the covered loans
people fell through the cracks and
absolutely what what the people that are
bearing the brunt of this are people
that are hard-working that again it's
that squeezed like lower middle which is
which is people that they can't they
don't qualify for any type of benefits
they're not getting any form of support
but really they're on the edge of trying
to decide between whether they feed
their families or they heat their homes
and how to get to work and i think
that's a real issue that families are
finding they can't afford the petrol how
do they therefore go and earn the money
they need so and people that just
getting onto the career the career
ladder as well that aren't able to
demand higher salary increases are
really being penalized yeah vicky price
i mean there does seem to be and it was
a feature of some aspects of the
pandemic and the lockdowns there does
seem to be this growing gap between the
generations economically
that's absolutely true but of course the
younger generation has been able to go
back to work and at least earn some
salary and you know the starting
salaries are about 20 to 25 000 some
people have been working part-time some
full-time but what you've seen is that
there has been quite an expansion in
job opportunities again and we have very
low unemployment
um pensioners some of them work but many
don't and the average
income if you like if you add everything
that a pensioner gets some from the
state pension but 67 of what
comes into the household comes from
private pensions it seems in the uk
um the average
income that i have is about 15 000
pounds
so it's not huge
and
the worst thing you'd want is to have
loads of poor pensioners
um and there had been an attempt to
ensure that that doesn't happen again
because of this triple lock which of
course as we know was abandoned last
year
so coming back to this makes sense up to
a point um because of the situation
which very many pensioners find
themselves seeing including of course
very high energy bills okay uh specific
question then from uh
one of the younger generation well i i i
i'm guessing that jade
is an international student um of course
may not necessarily be in that category
but asks this international students are
facing hard financial situations because
of inflation cost of living and very
high rent um gemma you might know this
maybe not are they eligible for any
supporting scheme from the government
international students i must admit i
did do a bit of research um you know in
anticipation of anything to do with
international students because i know
that there's a big need out there for
people to get support when they're
coming from another country um if you go
onto the the government's website there
is a list of different um schemes they
have available a lot also for uk uh
students to try and encourage them to go
abroad i mean i think the one the one in
particular that i spotted was something
around a postgraduate scholarship for
international students now of course
that isn't going to help people that are
on their first degree but there is and
also there are criteria involved in
order to be able to qualify for it um
but yeah i mean looking on the
government website and trying to
wade through the information there that
might help hopefully uh provide some
help and it depends on the college or
institution you may be studying at as
well they plenty of them have bursaries
and things like that don't they
yeah absolutely and i think i think the
main message here is to go and ask for
help because it's not in anybody's
interest for people to struggle and
especially when students are coming um
here and we've got such a talent
shortage and we really are crying out
for certain skills but again especially
when there are certain degrees and that
involves some apprenticeships as well
all of them actually you could then go
to the employer that's involved in that
that year that that sandwich year and
see if they can provide any support and
quite often they do they have certain
things that they can provide to support
people to make sure that they're getting
new talent into companies my goodness me
we're really ranging over the territory
stay with us thank you all very much
indeed plenty more roaming to go but
we've got to take a another break coming
up next we're going to be turning our
attention to the government what is it
doing to help struggling workers and
its policies simply not working
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back now the government is
saying it would be reckless to raise
public sector pay in line with inflation
after it hit a 40-year high today and
that record has been reached at the same
time as the most disruptive railway
strikes for three decades partly due to
a dispute about wages and tonight the
rmt union has confirmed that tomorrow's
strike will go ahead after accusing the
transport secretary grant chaps of
wrecking today's negotiations he's
responded by saying that is a total lie
as our business correspondent paul kelso
reports
the trains were back but not to normal
around 60 of services resuming on a day
sandwiched by strikes that have not yet
brought the nation to a halt but may
soon be testing patients i understand
why they're doing it um
but i also understand i think i
understand both perspectives to be
honest yeah i'm completely for it i
think
it's right to strike when you need to i
think i should get a bit more
even though it's impacted you how it has
it's caused you a lot of hassle you've
still got sympathy yeah they could do a
good job do you know what i mean the
decent guys they're polite and they're
nice and kind which i mean but i think
we should be given a little bit more
yeah
hopes of a breakthrough were always slim
but disappeared altogether after less
than three hours of talks the rmt
demanding what it says is a threat of
compulsory redundancies be dropped we
came back here today seeking for that
for it to be removed so that we can
negotiate a settlement to the dispute
but we have been told now by the highest
people in network rail they don't have
the authority to say that you can
withdraw that letter there's only one
place that could say that and that's in
an apartment for transport so it's
pretty clear the government have
scuppered these talks
transport secretary grant shaps called
that a total lie the network rails chief
negotiator concurred i'm so frustrated
because our aim this afternoon was to
move that
forward to make uh to move to the next
stage of that offer
and essentially but i can't do that on
my own i can't do that if the rmt are
walking out the room uh you know when at
the same time they're also threatening
me with a strike tomorrow we have to
work within the funding that we can make
available
i haven't got enough money to be able to
fund a seven percent pay rise
one train operator has settled a dispute
mersey rail agreeing a 7 pay rise with
staff from the tssa union but nationally
network rail says the industry faces a
crisis
in 2019 before the pandemic there were
1.7 billion passenger journeys
generating 11 billion pounds of revenue
but in the last year there were just 990
million journeys almost halving income
to 5.9 billion pounds
union members say they face their own
income squeeze one conductor told us the
rising cost of living demanded action
things are getting worse as time goes on
as food prices increase and energy
prices increase and that's on my current
salary if anyone is making a move to
potentially tinker with my terms and
conditions and it's already a struggle
that's just an inevitable situation that
i'm going to have to fight to protect
myself from
this was always a complex dispute about
more than money it's about modernization
about the future
of the railway but with relations
between the two sides having soured and
the government firmly blaming the unions
there seems little chance of substantial
progress until after strikes on thursday
and again on saturday have played out
until then the talks like many trains
will be going nowhere
paul kelso sky news in london
well as we've been hearing the rate of
inflation has risen to a new 40-year
high 9.1 percent how our people and
households been affected our panel of
experts are answering your questions
right now many many of them flooding
into us here at sky news uh joining us
for this are the personal finance expert
gemma godfrey chief economic advisor to
the center for economics and business
research vicky price
and professor adrian papst deputy
director of the national institute of
economic and social research so more
questions for you all thank you very
much indeed for your efforts so far um
this question coming from neil and um
adrian um
take this on board
neil asked what is the government doing
to help people who are in work but
struggling with rising inflation tell
you what i'll ask you the next one
because it's a big question gemma you
know some of the specifics please um
what is the government doing i mean
there are quite a few schemes and many
many billions of money being given out
by the government
yeah absolutely i mean the main ones to
talk about are the 400 pound energy
rebate and they moved that thing they
doubled it it used to be 200 pounds and
you'd have to repay it and now it's 400
pounds you don't have to pay it back and
it comes directly from the energy
provider and i think the other one is
you know 150 pounds um rebate on your
council tax but again only for specific
areas i mean those are the main ones the
other things that they because again the
question specifically was what's what
support is the government giving people
that are working there's a lot of the
other support for pensioners and some
people on universal credits so i think
the other thing i would i would point to
is that um there's a lot of pressure the
energy regulator is putting on energy
suppliers and it's great wording on
their website to try and afford try and
make sure that they're providing people
with affordable payment plans so i think
a lot of the shift is actually moving on
to people to speak up and speak to their
providers whether it's their bank their
suppliers or whatever it is and if
they're struggling to try and discuss
maybe moving you know reducing their
monthly payments having a break or
making sure that things are affordable
for them but having that discussion
directly okay that's good so that's if
you're in work that's what you are
entitled to but you've got to do quite a
lot of the leg work or certainly the
finger work yourself um so this one um
adrian from from uh sam if inflation is
so high does the government handing out
more money add to the problem do they
need to massively cut back their
spending are we in for another period of
retrenchment
well we've had periods of retrenchment
which uh did not help growth and did not
help uh you know real wage rises and
have in some sense landed us
in the current situation that we're in
uh we've been arguing for some time that
fiscal policy should be looser at a
point where investment is needed
where productivity is low growth are low
and therefore more money needs to be
targeted
uh because otherwise we're going to have
a an even deeper recession that we might
already have at the end of the year
and recessions tend to hit the poorest
hardest so there is no real argument
economically or socially for
retrenchment at this point the question
of course is what does government spend
the money on and there are better ways
and worse ways one way is to help the
poorest
and we might come back to this a little
later with more targeted help than the
government have put in place so far
um and then the other question is what
can public investment do to help unlock
private investment and to invest in the
right area skills
infrastructure transportation housing
and so on so that the economy grows at a
much faster rate that's the real problem
low growth low productivity low wages
it's a vicious circle and that's the
problem when we then also face with
global shocks as we are right now then
it becomes really critical again for the
bottom half of the income distribution
in particular well you've touched on the
concerns of our next question honor
asks are government policies simply not
working to improve the overall british
economy what more should they be doing
vicky price and adrian was touching on
it there wasn't any investment
productivity innovation so many other
areas
there's all that but of course that
takes time we've been talking about the
same problems for a very long period of
time so for decades now trying to
improve the productivity of the economy
there is an attempt to look at the
regions and uh the leveling up white
paper that the government put out
is trying to
uh at least sort of make sure that
very region many regions which in the
past did not receive very much of
government support in terms of
investment or even business support in
terms of private sector investment
get a fairer share infrastructure has
been poor in loads of parts of the uk
and if you look at productivity it's
been mainly
london and the southeast which have been
above the average for the uk whereas
everyone else is below that so there are
some big big gaps some big regional
issues that need to be sorted out we've
also got a problem with smaller firms
not being able to really get the finance
to expand now if we start getting into
position now where
monetary policies tightened and credits
becoming more expensive and the
availability of finance generally is not
going to be as free-flowing as before
then we will suffer long-term in terms
of productivity growth and the truth is
that if you look at the latest broadcast
from
the bank of england itself it just
assumes that over the next year we will
hardly see any growth at all and as has
been reported quite extensively the
organization for economic operation and
development the think tank for the
richer nations now things of the uk will
grow at the slowest pace than any
of the g20 countries the biggest 20
countries um in the world in terms of
gdp
except for russia
yeah what a fine line to tread who would
be a an economic policymaker um
fuel question yeah we knew you're going
to get one of those um daisy
asks this gemma domestic fuel and
vehicle fuel companies are claiming
price hikes are necessary yet seem to be
making huge profits why a lead is not
taking a stand against profiteering
i mean this is such a hard question
because what we've seen as the
government came forward and actually had
that attitude and gave her and charged a
windfall tax for the energy providers
for that exact reason you know they're
making much more money on the on the
price of energy therefore they should be
actually paying more tax and then they
came back and said but if you invest in
in future growth don't worry about it
you know we'll discount it and look i
can't speak for the government i don't
know why they haven't made a stand but
all i can say is is that the problem
with domestic fuel and vehicle companies
is is that you know they've tried to do
this for the big oil and energy
companies but what they're what they've
also seen an unintended consequence of
the higher energy prices is a lot of the
smaller companies went bust and because
the smaller companies went bust it meant
that there's less competition in the
market so for us as consumers going
online to try and find a better package
for our energy there just isn't enough
competition that's out there so you know
potentially there might be a bit of
caution there to try and target
companies too much because actually what
we need to do is we need to have more
choice out there
to be able to get better better pricing
another question on fuel
gemma asks this adrian why is the
government charging so much tax on fuel
it is true even with that 5p cut in judy
a few months back isn't it that um we
have some of the highest taxes on fuel
in europe
is right and it's been a very welcome uh
source of government revenue over you
know years and decades and
yes the 5p uh cut to fuel duty was no
doubt welcome by many motorists uh but
again the question is is that really the
right thing to do
when it proportionally benefits those
with big cars who drive a lot more and
are probably earning more than those who
need their car to commute
it just doesn't seem like the best way
of helping people
uh especially those who need it most uh
and absolutely we should look at fuel
duty as a structure but then of course
other aspects of the tax system as well
we've already touched on it a bit
we're taxing labour a lot so national
insurance contributions went up in april
uh are we taxing capital uh in the same
way
and then there's questions over land tax
and all sorts of other taxation but also
for example taxes on certain businesses
have done extremely well during the
pandemic like the tech platforms
uh and and i think that needs to be
something done in the round rather than
going for one thing and thinking that
somehow that's going to make a big
difference it very very does the tax
system needs profound reform that needs
to be thought through but things can be
done very differently than they have
been done over the last few years or
decades and of course when it comes to
fuel taxes you mustn't forget the
climate agenda listen we're going to
take another break now coming up next
we're going to be asking will prices go
down when if inflation is under control
stay with us
[Music]
what we are trying to do is create a
community
project where people that have been
censored online specifically by social
media platforms by algorithms and ai can
actually have their images um seen
so the unseen becomes seen and it's
really to create a discussion most of
the community most of the participants
actually love the platforms but the
platforms unfortunately have got no
common sense in terms of what they're
actually censoring so although most of
us agree with censorship we don't agree
with the censorship of these types of
images
some of some of the imagery that there
is censored by social media platforms
should be sensitive the thing about this
type of imagery is it's been is it's a
kind of
one-size-fits-all
uh
practice which is taking images that
shouldn't be centered and the one
problem that we have with it the main
problem in fact is there's no recourse
there's nobody to speak to at the social
media platforms you can't connect with
them it's that even the the the
the when you want to complain about uh
your work being uh censored or even your
platform being shut down it's it's a
letter you get one letter um you have to
complain multiple times and you can
never ever speak to somebody about it if
you go and see the show in real life the
imagery in there isn't anything that you
would you would be worried about your
children seeing uh it's pretty um you
know safe in all honesty it's pretty a
lot of it's to do with uh societal and
cultural
norms some of its small businesses
disability some of it's a bit political
and i think that the problem is is that
you know we keep coming up against this
similar thing with all the platforms
where it's a one-way street and it's
there's no common sense used like all of
these uh participants in this show they
love the platforms they really want
their work to be seen and if you imagine
being a young photographer wanting your
work to be seen or a young creative and
it being shut down because of this as i
said one-size-fits-all policy it really
is very frustrating and i think when you
understand that most of this work is
actually the product that the social
media platforms are selling advertising
on top of it would be nice if it was
more of a two-way street
[Music]
welcome back as you know by now our
panel of experts are answering your
questions after yet another increase in
inflation today so uh let's get into the
last section of this hour on
inflation and the cost of living we've
got a very direct question from paul but
it is the question that everyone's
asking and uh i'd like all of you to
answer it for me paul just simply asked
are we on course for a recession so well
let's start with the the economist
definition of a recession vicki price i
mean it is quite a narrow definition
isn't it it's two quarters of negative
growth so i mean it could be you know
very small negative growth so not much
of a recession but it then also could be
a howling global
slump which really caused causes pain
it could uh we don't really know what's
going to happen in ukraine i mean the
war
may last for quite some time so we may
have high oil prices high gas prices
real food shortages for quite some time
now the question of course is going to
be uh are those prices going to continue
to increase or are they just going to
stay at high levels if there's just at
high levels what we might find is that
inflation in fact slows down quite
significantly because you're comparing a
year ago with
where prices are now that's the way in
which you measure that inflation
and obviously if wages up to a point
catch up
then people might continue to spend but
for the moment the real worry is that
because of the squeeze in living
standards and if inflation and prices
stay high
then our consumers are just not going to
spend and we're beginning to see that
happening already and certainly in the
uk we had two core two months rather of
negative growth which was march and
april you do need as you rightly say
two quarters of negative growth for this
but the real worry that everyone has is
not just that you might have recession
even you know relatively mild recession
we might be able to
um recover from that
the real concern i have is that if the
monetary policy
reaction because we had a question
before about interest rates going up to
five percent if it is pretty tough in
order to bring inflation down
domestically you really need to slow the
economy down very significantly so the
concern is that we might end up with a
global
depression not just recession and
that's why i think central bankers have
tended to be reasonably cautious before
raising rates i mean remember we have in
europe
the european central bank which still
has a negative rate there we have a
number of other countries such as
switzerland for example which raised
this rates by 50 basis point hooray the
swiss franc went up it went up quite
significantly when they raised their
interest rates from minus 0.75 percent
to minus 0.25 and in japan is still
negative yeah how interesting um
adrian perhaps address this question i
mean vicki price was
talking about that the role of
psychology i suppose in recessions
talking ourselves into a recession
thinking ourselves into a recession
consumer behavior i suppose business
investment behavior there's a danger
that's the talk of recession becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy
yes absolutely so much of the economies
about confidence is about
spending is about investments and if
people are uh quite gloomy about the
future and of course they might simply
uh defer their spending to further
investment hoping that things will look
a bit rosier uh further down the line so
that is definitely a problem which is
why strong
leadership is necessary by both the
fiscal policy makers and the monetary
policy makers to chart a course
even if there is this heightened
uncertainty but we've had uncertainty
before with brexit with covid
that's the job of policymakers to reduce
uncertainty wherever possible show a
path out of this and make some of the
tough decisions in order for example to
bring forward some investment not just
through tax deduction but also by
unlocking
uh investment there is a lot of money
around but it doesn't get spent or
invested and the question is how do we
channel into productive activities so
that the economy can grow especially in
the areas that are lagging behind where
there is huge need but also huge
potential and that is of course the
leveling up challenge some short term
gained or short term wins are possible
you know you can invest in skills now
that will help you with the later market
in six 12 months
and so there's all sorts of things that
can be done to avert this
gemma give me the consumer perspective i
mean we are covering right here on sky
news on a daily basis just how badly
some people are suffering they're not
making conscious choices to preserve
their money they just don't have enough
cash
absolutely i mean this is one of the
biggest dips in people's disposable
income and people didn't really have a
buffer anyway uh to kind of fall into
and that is the big concern you know
they're fighting on all fronts as i said
you know food housing heating transport
there's kind of no respite and what's
interesting is is that when we talk
about interest rates and they're at the
highest level in 30 years and yes
they're still at historic lows but these
are unprecedented times for a lot of
people a lot of people have never
experienced this before they're used to
low interest rates low inflation and it
means that this is an entire way of
managing your finances trying to
anticipate a continuing rise in cost of
living you know on all your essential
goods and also what's interesting as
well is that you know yes interest
higher interest rates are penalizing
people that are borrowers for example so
people have variable mortgages but
what's bigger concern is that it's not
really being passed through to save us
and that would be the hope is that
people then be able to save more and
earn more and it's not happening so
people are really really struggling okay
um our economists a quick thought i'll
roll two questions together they're
pretty similar ian and jeff are all
really asking this you know where's the
inflation coming from i'm going to
paraphrase we'll put up um one of them
on the screen but i'm going to
paraphrase you know is it homegrown or
is it imported or is it a bit of both
vicky price
it's mostly imported
um it's energy and it's food and those
are global issues and all countries that
we know are suffering from the same
problem even the ones i mentioned
earlier which have quite low inflation
are beginning to see a little bit more
of that happening and the war in ukraine
has been a major contributory factor
okay uh adrian pabst that a bit from
jeff's question i wonder if we can put
it up there um
is it beyond our control really a lot of
this inflation then is there not much we
can do about it
the factors leading to the situation are
uh to a large extent beyond our control
but there are things that can be done
through monetary policy by the interest
rates or the rolling back of of qe of
asset purchases by the bank of england
setting a clear course
using fiscal policy more to uh help the
poorest but also target investments so
there are things that we can do
especially to get growth up and so yes
inflation for the moment is high but we
shouldn't be saying saying well this is
all global and therefore nothing can be
done and just sit back and wait that
would be a terrible cause policymaking
needs to be more proactive
okay and uh lastly to round off this i
mean illuminating session if i don't get
time to thank you at the end i'll thank
you all now it's been so so informative
uh gemma take this for us ken you know
everyone's wondering will prices go down
when inflation is under control or i'm
just thinking about that question ken
actually will inflation be under control
when prices have gone down
and i think actually vicki
articulated this so clearly which is
it's really important to get our heads
around which is inflation doesn't mean
high prices it means rising prices so
what actually could happen is people
again it could be all across the news
don't worry inflation is under control
but prices could still be high what it
could mean is they've just stabilized
you know the hope would be as if they
stabilize people get time to be able to
um you know readjust to it you get more
competition in the market you know then
obviously the hope would be that things
will be able to improve after that but
there are quite a few stages we have to
go through and keeping in mind we're set
to see another increase in the energy
cap in october so
and also when we talk about interest
rates they weren't raised as much as
people expected so we're more likely to
see maybe more aggressive um rate rises
further down the line so there's still
quite a lot of pressure coming uh before
before we're in that in that scenario oh
yeah more pain to come listen thank you
all
so so much you've been absolutely
brilliant gemma godfrey vicky price
professor adrian pabst thank you very
much indeed i'm sure we'll all meet
again this is clearly a subject that
requires an awful lot of examination
thank you